Good evening!
(audience applauding)
You're too kind!
I'm following the president, or something.
Oh, this is so exciting.
Big week, big week, ladies and gentlemen.
The new iPhone is out, yeah.
I have a love hate relationship with my iPhone.
I basically think that smartphones
have got too smart for their own good.
I miss having a dumb phone.
Do you know the phone I miss every day of my life?
The Nokia 3310
(audience cheering)
Oh!
That was a phone!
Screw the iPhone with all of its apps,
and its maps, and this GPS crap!
The Nokia 3310 gave a man all he needed,
stopwatch, calculator, and Snake, screw anything else!
I loved that phone.
And there was no pretension with the 3310 as well.
Predictive text messaging on the 3310.
Oh, it was bliss, do you remember that?
If you tried to type in a word to the 3310
that was more than four letters long,
it would just give up.
"Yeah, you want to use fancy pants language like that,
you're on your own, mate!"
Not the iPhone.
Where did the iPhone get its vocabulary?
It doesn't matter what you type in, A-N,
"Did you mean androgynous?"
"No!
"I meant and!"
(audience laughing)
It's very nice to be here.
It's very nice to be here in New York.
It's very nice to be anywhere right now, yeah.
(audience cheering)
Back home, we're going through
quite a nasty divorce right now, called Brexit.
And I want to take this opportunity,
on behalf of my nation, to thank you, America.
I want to thank you from the bottom of our hearts.
We owe you a huge debt of thanks
because we woke up after Brexit,
and I'm not gonna lie, we thought,
"That is it, we are screwed."
"We are now gonna be the most
ridiculed nation on the planet."
And then, last November, you guys went, "Hold my beer."
(audience cheering)
Thank you.
There are some angry people in this country right now.
Oh my God, you're living in a country
where there were people that boycotted
Disney's Beauty and the Beast
because it had a gay character in it.
Yeah, the Christian right were up in arms,
a gay character in Beauty and the Beast.
They were like, "It's against God's law."
The film is about a girl shagging a buffalo.
(audience laughing)
I love Disney, I love Disney, but I've been tested.
My love of Disney has been tested this year.
Earlier on this year, I stayed over here.
They messed up my hotel booking.
And I had to stay in the Disney Hotel
for a month of my life as a grown man.
I nearly turned into Jack Nicholson from the Shining.
Because it is too much Disney at the Disney Hotel.
There's Disney music in every elevator.
There's Disney characters on the walls and the bed linen.
Disney characters embroidered onto all
of the towels in the bathroom.
Yes!
I know that sounds sweet, until you're drying your testicles
on the face of the old man from Up.
Just there,
(audience laughing)
in the bathroom, teabagging a grieving senior citizen.
You're like, "Oh, I'm sorry about your wife."
Disney characters that work at the hotel
as members of staff, that by company policy,
are not allowed to break character
at any point during your stay.
Have you got any idea how annoying that is?
You check in, and Goofy's on reception.
Walk into the restaurant, Donald Duck's doing teppenyaki.
I can pinpoint, though, the exact moment
that my childhood died.
I'd been there for two weeks.
I was in my room, I was tired, I was alone.
I called down to the front desk,
Mickey Mouse answers the phone,
"Hey, hey, hey, buddy, what can I do for you today?"
"Mickey,
I need to activate the porn channels on my TV."
(audience laughing)
Inner child's dead.
You don't want this interaction.
These are your childhood heroes.
Arguing with Simba at the front desk
about your itemized bill,
"Listen mate, I want to speak with someone more senior.
"Fetch me
Mufasa!"
(audience laughing)
Ladies and gentlemen, thank you very much!
I am Jack Whitehall, goodnight.